this
you know testing the testing and we love
and we love let me know if we laugh
alright chat I'm kind of winning this
show I got no addict but boy boomstick
Excel is in a building but um I need you
to talk to me if y'all can hear me and
also hear this game award stuff fine in
the back deaf I sent you to invite bro
Chuck you're drunk Brandon Bryce what's
going on keep it flat for life what's
going on
can y'all can y'all hear me I need some
chat so I'm in the chat let me know yeah
I can hear me alright so y'all can hear
me okay keep it flat can you do me a
favor can you tell me if y'all can hear
the actual game Awards
can y'all hear that I feel you grab for
God alright cool Luis Jimenez thank you
brother
can you guys hear the game Awards I need
to know that that's very important
CAI box I don't care about your destiny
for me thank you sir Damon Percival loud
and clear no doubt but Game Awards can
you hear the stream is it low or is it
high and I louder than the game Awards
is the game awards volume louder than me
let me know I don't hear anything okay
they said they can hear random bytes as
you can hear the game awards music
that's good
alright so Luis Jimenez which one is a
little low or I am low okay
I'm louder than the Game Awards thank
you that's what I needed to know all
right let me bring myself down a little
bit
all right so I try to bring myself down
a little bit see what
now you are you bringing up all you
bring in the Game Awards up on the
screen no yeah cuz basically what you do
boom is on just if you want to watch
YouTube you you're gonna have to watch
it either through on IOP with me or
watch it off for YouTube yourself while
we're doing it okay
I see I see what you're saying yeah yeah
game what's got louder guys I just
turned out I just turned up sound good
how here thank you brother it means a
lot thank you so much I'm winging this
right now addict was supposed to have
this setup somewhere I had to come in
here late blame addict slam what's going
on slim yeah super Chapter VI stuff now
if I get you another invite brother
all right let's get this
yeah well I'm launching it from our ILP
okay cool thank you bro yeah it looks
like so far they say they can hear
everything so I'm actually surprised
message to you got loud real quick I got
what loud
okay okay
next three minutes are three minutes
absolutely you should have an invite sir
there's a good question wrong school
tech what's up man all school I need you
brother you too man
do me a favor school let me know in the
chat on out of volume sound in
relationship to the game of what violent
relationships and the people in the
chair in my life
check your DM so I sent it to sound
brother
pre-show first okay thank you
Tetris my man school I appreciate you
what Kings working yeah I don't Kings
work in I think saws working too so
we're trying to get done last minute as
well I think Forte supposed to be
rocking out and then I'm what you call
it uh not equal join in progress that's
cool
def stranding sweet tonight okay school
okay everybody's got the Jeff stranded
hat
we'll talk a little bit I don't know if
the people can hear you yeah how do I
sound guys I'm right up on the mic and
she could hear me just fine we got
double-barrel gaming man make sure y'all
get here I'm gonna go back the arrow
tool that's struggling for the win
anything hot air goes there see this
friend it's gonna get a bunch of
musicals and then it's the win game of
the year it's gonna do a Red Dead
Redemption to slim sounds boom is good
other Zeke was good
so definitely yeah the game award music
is is is I think a little bit loud oh
it's too loud okay yeah okay you're just
just a little bit a little bit down I
got you I got you I put it down now I
put us about level okay and I put it I
put a different I mean that that's the
game boys right down so deaf man are we
gonna get excited about some gears
tactics X calms down are we gonna get
easy yes yes we are especially for the
inmates when I stir my night and
hopefully soon yeah I'm I'm all for it
oh man what you looking forward to we're
talk to us boom you know it's funny I'm
hoping to see Batman something with
Batman they did a do that a couple years
ago where they brought a big present on
stage with Mark Hamill doing the
voice-over which was dope mm-hm
I'd like to get a release date for Gears
tactics
there's a repeat dude what's the reaper
you hear that I I hear what you say what
you echo or something yeah
because I'm it you know what it is maybe
because the the the actual game Awards
is playing it maybe for you though cuz I
thought uh no one say they had an echo
yeah school schools on he said no echo
that's not so it maybe you have two
versions of it up or you're listening to
you yes since that we could okay that's
weird
you may have to mute one of your sources
I don't know how if you just watched it
from ILP and then you're also hearing it
in the stream possibly maybe okay here
we go
trash they'll be good alright it's gonna
be a big one man how many awards that's
trending you think I can go get talk to
me six wow I bet that's what I said I
said I said I said anyway I thought six
for sure it's gonna get so soon as they
go right they go right in yeah same
brother good to watch it with your
brothers
what's up everyone I'm sippy Goodman and
I will be your help
Awards 2019 a pre-show the game awards
will begin at the top of the hour
featuring musical performances by Green
Day Grimes and churches and brand-new
looks at ghosts of Tsushima and gears
tactics but while the Microsoft Theater
fills in behind me and the world gets
their popcorn ready we've got 30 minutes
of Awards special guests and world
premieres of our own right here in the
pre-show including a brand new trailer
for final fantasy 7 destiny 2 for best
community support our let's go dusty we
need one man you haven't got one
[Applause]
and Rainbow six siege and the winner is
drumroll please Wow I've never thought
this day what happened this is really an
honor
I got acknowledge the people at Meiji
who've worked so hard to you know
support our community starting with our
community team who are on the front
lines every day interacting with our
fans the core development team our
operations folks like everyone up and
down just cares so much about this game
and I just got acknowledged all their
hard work the only thing I'd add is
everyone here creates entertainment and
what use is creating entertainment you
don't have awesome fans huge
congratulations to destiny - for winning
our first ever best community support
it's no coincidence
they are also up for best ongoing I mean
listen I mean I'm gonna be honest with
you the choices were weren't the
greatest but I mean destiny - has on
games and reveals here's the first yeah
big dick community doesn't work -
community does let's be real true I
consider cosmic disturbance we must be
prepared for the worst
all time to change history for the
better I had the first world for me
hey someone's I'm a little bit head to
pose here
but it's gonna be fun just relax
do you have any idea who you're up
against
yeah I'm talking low school a doubt
degree lemming office tada
welcome to the danger room I hope you
survive the experience
the Phoenix force has reawakened in 2018
the Game Awards teamed up with Facebook
gaming to honor global gaming citizens
people from all areas of gaming who use
the power of games to create a positive
influence tonight I'm joined by one of
the global gaming citizens we met last
year who has a new project to show us
please welcome
Luol my in thank you so much thank you
so much have you been working on yo for
sure today then I taught myself how to
create a video game
my mission we got dad was the move and
now des tika whistle was because be back
to visit around here we go he's gonna
win it
I think a new horse is gonna win its
best score mixer could I what oh no no I
know who what I see the sir
Kingdom Hearts 3 yeah
you should be a mixer just to get Ed's
death strand here we go
[Laughter]
[Music]
here we go that's one that's going on I
don't know what to do I like your colors
how are you feeling I've been nervous
this whole week and I can't believe this
is happening right now I just want to
say big things and shout out and also a
congratulations to lower churches I'm
just super happy to be here and I'm
super super weird and I hope we can keep
on doing weird [ __ ] going forward one
game featured an interesting game I feel
like I'm up here watching watching the
episode of inside Xbox 80 style know
this game by the gate looks like I
always wanted to be jaws yeah I'm buying
this game I'm telling you right now I'm
buying oh yeah it's time to even the
score
oh yeah Judas is if the feels like it's
a few minutes ahead
22nd
because when they announce projects of
Scarlets night I got your chick got the
chick for the screen yes
[Applause]
[Music]
and the International 2019 and the
winner is
League of Legends World Championship yes
thank you very much machine
she to eSports come on - we may May yeah
the Europeans let's go oh you just doing
a regional bias okay I see what you're
doing g2 eSports thank you very much yes
how much money what's up to everyone
watching the game Awards live in movie
theaters across 50 cities where the game
awards are part of a special double
feature with Jumanji the next level
we're about to take a short break but
first here's a little message from a
couple I do they had to do it come on
we checked out Drock why you wanna say
Xbox girl was ever infants trippy now I
feel like now I feel like they gave
Bungie that award because you know why
because this isn't part of the show this
is like it's like these are all things
to do so let's just get the trash out
yeah it felt like they put us with a
kitty could it was like I get up out of
here
what's this oh god are they but to say
six months the Xbox gamepad for six
dollars no I think are they going
through game pass nominees oh nice I'd
like to yes good well done Xbox yes good
connection Phil Spencer sitting there
like we got to make these people know
that game pass is a good dog the
untitled goose gay got so much play on
brass yesterday I couldn't move very
good very good as well the next focus he
said you see starches first three months
for three dollars one year fifties hence
the water year fifty cents
I'm paid up to 2022 man I'm good I'm all
the way right to the end of 2021 welcome
back to the game Awards pre-show this
summer I had the pleasure of joining
pretty empty in there and one of the
games we revealed that night was
completed studios I just realized it
when I was looking us like why is the
clock still countdown oh this isn't even
a show yet they basically just here's a
participation award I'll still walking
away with the same trophies everybody
they can call the game play the game
because they don't play understand
achievements as you select cultures and
that sort of thing don't understand the
struggles of a gamer that plays one game
and the Galea mountain identity of how
you changed humankind we have tons of
ideas of where the Avatar system you
know you really don't seem like you're
interested in what he's saying to you I
would agree she's very seem another fake
laugh right there why don't we take a
look you know like in the dress
Sega Oh premier that's good
whoa see these world food don't sound
like that
oh my god I'm watching on my phones out
and the computer is a 20 seconds crazy
with the hexagon us mistake bringing
infantry to a cavalry fight in the arms
race where you guys walking it
eventually
Mickey's prevailed and we came to the
bill bending oh yeah you can bet with
Blaine it on me and then I'll get the
blame on humankind yeah
humankind Sega honestly haven't even
told me what it is yet so I have just as
in the dark because anything big
announcement has to be won an award bro
bro it was the first I first I'm super
happy that they kind of did a study cuz
it was like the person wanted nobody in
the crowd and nobody was there was like
it looks like an 80s cartoon gonna say
70s yeah it looks like a 70s cartoon
interested in art style I guess
everyone's coughing off that cup head
yes definitely animation shot
look at these Dragon Ball Z wannabes man
like some will call Goku these people
are too much Mike Tyson knock me out and
play don't tell me this to not go off
there pops out the back bring out the
celebrating for gaming at the past week
with a special gaming on tick-tock
challenge tonight use the gaming on
tick-tock hashtag to show us how you're
celebrating video games biggest night
lastly we're shouting out the most
active game communities on reddit in
2019 for tonight PR League of Legends
and destiny the game but now I think
it's time for another world premiere
here is a brand new trailer for one of
next year's most anticipated games
ghosts you know it's gold
let's go plow
yeah they better not screw it up now I
don't think they're going to do it I
think this is gonna be epic man every I
really do owe to dangerous things
Brina
[Music]
so so keep your distance
what was his name again Wow music Cloud
Strife this is a one time game when it's
done we're done come on
no but do you do something this crazy
just for money the music at it worry
less about the planet and more about the
next box oh you know I I have this on
saved on a play with my feet bro that is
my feet well hold on he wasn't supposed
to do that
that didn't happen
[Music]
typical looking awful night no tip
looking night
that is the greatest we go yeah cat
daddy was the more and more looking a
gamepad here in our pre-show here are
the nominees this is a joke
jump for should be nowhere near this
list I think we all win this is a
problem and we ain't giving up the
December I should because you know it
would be a shame right now
someone from Mortal Kombat came down
what's up and the fact that all of this
comes together so seamlessly and so
beautifully is really a testament to the
dedication to the hard work and he has
to smash in on this award is for them
very very much
well congratulations you know I
understand gamers from last year it's
gonna win it I'm not gonna say anything
about I mean resident choose my pick for
Daniel and like I said I want des
trending to win just to watch the fires
burn I put in a burn for it for a
weekend again but I want smash to me and
I think well I think smash is gonna win
but I want a sec Reata where I'm really
wanting to win it's not gonna happen but
it will win do it don't want Star Wars
to win it's not even nominated well yeah
at once tell us to win as well but since
it's not there towards our award was
really good
I need Pavarti to win yep but we are
these already moving chairs around
[Laughter]
what's going on his van as you know they
had to give des training this so they
have to poor Sony in the movie venue
yeah
now he's getting the golden throw we'll
check this out look we're Kojima sir
he's 11 entire honor guard and
everything
took a spooky
that's Beth and uh stranden isn't it
it's gonna be the hi is like dripping
down like that that black [ __ ] from the
game thing Italian we we start the show
off with kijima stuff on stage okajima
made every game that's being nominated
it's literally raining on that stage it
is it's literally raining on a stage
yeah she's got a water thing in front of
her it's an effect they use it's not
actually raining on it yeah you got to
give me a thousand extra dollars to that
water my bow so much might hit yourself
[Music]
Oh Lord look at all that wasteland that
you walk around I think that I think
this is horrible I think this is already
better than dead stranding it's owning
an X 20 mm ringing out the orchestra
it's noise as a halo that would be sad
that would be salad Master Chief carry
on his back he's got Xbox 1x stack about
20 feet high
he's trying to look like she done
screwed up her her mascara all kinds why
is she out here I am villainous I'm
feeling this deaf stranding music
you halo in the air you know everyone in
the chat say an Xbox based on this video
so I'm pretty pretty sure this is gonna
get the Red Dead Redemption to treatment
because it's gonna win everything but
game of the year a smoker or log is
sitting next to bill tonight with no
ledger
[Music]
the talons behave they're gonna be six
different skills just just to get that
fast
Oh dick they could do a reunion oh wait
they can't because two people are
missing from last year's the one that
the one left standing is the real man oh
man worthy seen the most North won't
learn anything on that was the
african-american that was sitting in the
background like what are we doing
oh god what is this
I need to fix this how many times can
you count deaths training in this one
trailer I thought I detected three will
the water
I ain't gonna lie this um that water
warcraft trailer fire it is that war
warcraft rebels fire hi-c managed let's
punish yo yeah yeah no don't you play
with me yo that was for Santos gonna
feel better now please let us help
I don't even I don't even want to put
that negative energy out there it is
such an honor to be here you guys ready
to celebrate video games tonight I can't
believe this is the fifth anniversary of
the show and it's so great to have all
of you here we've got so many amazing
special guests mr. kijima one of the
things that really amazes me about this
show is how we connect the world around
games and we are live on over why you
guys they connect the world like that
hello everyone here there's a lot of
innuendos here I just three copies
addressed Randi I'm a wine to celebrate
video games now our show tonight yes
we're gonna have awards yes we're gonna
have a lot of brand-new game
announcements and surprises for you so
stay tuned for that you know you like
those and we've also got performances by
Green Day Westworld please welcome
Jonathan Nolan
[Applause]
everybody doing evening I'm here to
present the Award for Best narrative
chapter will it take us with branching
storylines to change based on their
actions it's an idea that we should just
say that's strong didn't why you've got
to talk about it
this training is in this in this award
is it almost all yes stop talking and
just say that's the first season that
with world's fire all hugely influential
on our work and you can see the echoes
of those games in our show the West
world is gonna win why does his speech
have to be so long just saying we all
know what it's good we don't know the
buildup in the exposition what she
warned is about we just need to know so
it's know that you shouldn't uh there
might be a laugh a laugh everybody laugh
a plague still control control have a
pretty decent narratives okay dis dis
going
whoa whoa you guys Wow I'm ahead of you
and I'm sorry zo disco disco desert yes
[Applause]
Nick said that way he said that some
similar to pillars of eternity in thank
everyone who believed this game exists
when we first started talking about it
have anything it will just you know Josh
in here but it's nice when the little
guy you know it's it's like the little
engine that could I mean look look what
it was against you know I'm saying that
this is this is when you see something
special force it was it's you doing did
you see the people you see other games
that it was running up against but I'm
happy all right let's be real here let's
be right here they say I've art they
gave dust ready gave the year they'll
give it everyone else everything else
now control is gonna get game of the
year including coach streamers so sounds
like you guys are excited about what we
have going on of course we're live on
over 50 platforms and the fans on
Twitter predicting who will take home
the Game Awards tonight right now we've
got a poll we'll open with the twitch
extension who does the audience think is
gonna win the best eSports player award
you can vote now in a little while we'll
take a look at your predictions it's
gonna be fake I've got more Awards great
music where are you watching I'm talking
to and then sometimes there surprises
I'm watching our mixes oh yeah we're oh
he said out of nowhere
world premiere Shh I'm ahead of you guys
I'm gonna keep my mom my mouth shut for
something we're shakin let's suppose
that you were able every night to dream
any dream you wanted to dream uh-huh and
that you could have the power within one
night to dream 75 years of time that's
Joey mm ring it's gotta be Eldon ring oh
yeah maybe naturally as you began on
this adventure of Dreams fulfill all
your wishes me
but now let's I've come - lets go - it's
it's ex-con three it's gotta be yeah
Eldon ring Shirley then the gold
what consoles to power your dreams I
gotta hear this
see a future where they were instantly
absorbed in your games where worlds are
even more like like serious responsive
and surprising where you next holiday
Xbox series Xbox is a server you see the
green in the middle of the beam Xbox
game studios are developing the largest
and most creatively diverse lineup of
exclusive games in our history oh here
we go tonight I'm proud
the system is of its creative team this
thing's gonna be Monster is gross
here we go what you're about to see was
all captured Appian engine as being
built oh here we go from Ninja Theory
yup this he'll play to Disney I Bethany
[Laughter]
there's a new project Brown
give me a reason to buy next much SX you
got it I will never slander this the
game I want yes oh man yes I don't know
I don't care
a experiences yep no honey i shrunk the
key
they said xbox need to triple-a games
they [ __ ] gave you the game whoops
language now Blade 2 sources Sonja was
saga Xbox series X that's all the hit
y'all think my kiss I done took the show
happily been Danny served is he happily
this is what I'm fun player and the
results are in twitch community picked
faker yo they showed the new console you
guys called it correctly and still the
combination I never know what to say
he's by Green Day and Grimes I never
thought they would do so he did exactly
what we've been begging you amazing
stories about Global Gaming citizens I'm
so proud to have these in the show and
wreak a we say this is what I'm talking
about
I was born as an Afghan I'm glad that
they're taking the video game award
seriously in terms of like announcements
like late they literally just announced
the next console at the video game what
a junkie we gotta do what did Jeff got
to do to get that amount you know
Randolph or just FYI we called it salute
the rain when they see the game that
they are Oh Jack food is a place they
should go on outside and so further
do Microsoft literally doing everything
right right now I didn't think this
morning I would be waking up to on what
I wanted off is exclusive no questions
exclusive yeah dude come on you kidding
me this is a project that's for the Xbox
[Music]
well they can attempt to fight help
let's do this is already better than III
EDX let's have a talk here man so
Microsoft literally just announced
oh that's their new doctor time y'all
this is dr. Tao for the pride Microsoft
literally just announced their brand new
system releasing next year the holidays
we can't get anything like this at their
own let's be rude the reason they did is
because they wanted to surprise people
people wouldn't have expected EXO but if
it was announced there they would have
been so they were oh yeah this that
makes sense no one ever expected it we
announced it
but besides you show a facade you give
the need you show up one of the most
highly anticipated Ninja Theory game
exclusive in in
but you can end a show with that yeah
what the hell will they do in IE 3 yes
look man
Allah Allah Oh control one all I know is
one that one trailer has convinced me to
go buy an xbox xx as much as I know and
lunches I know my people will say now
you know you could play that on a PC
with I'm light but that Xbox looks like
a freaking server this is where I grew a
Forte from now on this is how marketing
has to go you share how the base is that
we are missing from the from the
actually know that other stuff inside
Xbox to be fair they look like the
design of that the design of the next
Xbox looks like something that would
literally be in your house do did you
see the vent on the telephone the net on
the top is gonna is telling me more than
anything else because Mike because the
one thing that everybody's been trying
to fight against when I kept saying dog
this is gonna be $600 everybody keeps
fighting against it saying well they
can't fix all the stuff they want into
the system at that price point but
looking at that system and that then on
the top lets me know that cooling is
among the most important thing they're
doing and I can see something like a 20
ATT I have a type of performance in it
with something like that that looks like
a freaking seal now look like a console
growth it looks like a PC port sir it
looks dude let's tell you something it's
it looks like a rake it does and it goes
in
really and now that you think about it
and I don't know why the none of us put
this together the whole initiative with
them wanting to go to PC or have their
games everywhere if your high-end system
looks like a PC where's the disconnect
there is no there is no disconnect
because you're basically telling
everybody that you're high NP x max is a
console with PC with PC architecture in
it I could put that next to my PC at
home because I've seen rigs go
horizontal as well I mean you know
you've seen those but I gotta tell you
man that's a slick design dude and I got
and here's the other thing
how how big of balls the Spencer has to
have to show that almost a year away I'm
looking for pictures of it to kind of
just do some investigations dude I can't
find them did they kept that at Iraq I'm
floored bro I was so excited could I
preordered down forgive me the ninja
spices beautiful
easy though she is she beautiful woman
he got my gearbox to do yeah what gear
by showing this
the chelation they ain't showing us the
end game of water - that's trash
I was this neo2 is it it's a PlayStation
game no I think it's the other one
yeah
[Music]
did that new games they're making is
this a PlayStation exclusive it had the
PlayStation logo on this look Anna do
you likely got our fool tip dark stove
if stork Tso's now it's God God pools
Xbox series X take my money to who made
who made an art form gearbox steer box
that looks 5:5 okay and that's a launch
title for them it's official launch well
it says it says holiday 2020 yes I'm
liking the show already Geoff Keighley
keep it as a brand you're making us
forget that you yes so we're here to
reinvent combat for loot driven action
RPGs combat salute you can also play the
game in solo as well as in co-op it's
gonna be fun for everyone
well it looks absolutely incredible that
was all in engine just don't say it's
the Destiny killer and we're fine
gearbox his point of view you guys
nominated oh man you know we love our
co-op and our gear at gearbox so here we
are man when and when I key showed us
God fall it was so amazing to us we had
to call her friends over at Sony our
friends over at Epic say hey help us
make this work on your epic it's coming
on the epic game store key three know
everything we can for you man
oh this is launch exclusively on the
PlayStation 5 and epic game store this
holiday
oh it's come to PC
I don't need to buy ps5 you sure well
seems like something relationship so in
the category of best audio design for
best in-game audio and sound design
those nominees are alright let's go call
duty modern warfare control death
stranding please give us the gears I
gave it to Sakura guys I got a picture
of this age of Wonders I got a picture
of the Xbox here I'm blown I'm looking
at it right now they have to win it that
that content creator of the year mr.
boomstick and I appreciated I will take
your hands and I will accept your pile
[Applause]
we've had some great world premieres and
announcements to start off the show and
we've talked about Xbox we've talked
about PlayStation switch platform we
probably should talk about now premier
brand new game announcement that I don't
think you guys are expecting but it were
really a beauty you guys for someone
ruins this
Oh
bravery default question mark it is
Preto gnomes accept your fate in a way
to oblivion
dude this is bravery default I'm gonna
flip out and fight oh this is very
different-looking flip out step into the
role breathe deep oh it's got to be
watch it be some wack-ass way to know
the creator
[Music]
I think at the new game
they will keep putting bravery default
if it's bravery befall
[Music]
it's bravery equal to
[Music]
oh damn I switch for another year
[Laughter]
alright everyone got a little bit of
something nice I got a lot you gets a
great point everyone you know everyone
got their shot in Rebecca for live
operations the community director at
Digital Extremes that for Canada for
Rebecca for both alright Rebecca welcome
to the Game Awards you've been up here
before
okok I'm sending you picture right now
we've making this game for seven years
in each year we updated with it space
ninja Flair but uh we think it's time to
go space pirate and this whole impure
yes I know you guys have teased that
what can you tell us about it what's
gonna come out well we were thinking on
PC we would launch it right now okay
here we go and people be able to get
their hands on it tonight
anything else preparing for empyrion
Nintendo switch will come soon and it's
really just uh if you've been following
warframes story there's a lot to find in
this update so why not launch it on PC
okay so it's out right now on PC and we
take a look at it okay people's already
tagging me on Twitter saying here's your
mini-fridge talking about the Xbox was
she was the developer she was talking
about warframe it's coming on PC
whatever it is she said
let's see I might need to download it
off steam let's go work warframes now on
PC it is on PC cartogram yeah it must
must be a new expansion I can't move
this game just keeps going and going and
going it's got the loads of support yeah
hey spoilers wait so disrespectful
Oh what weekend Spaceballs sing would I
go front destiny need that wait
oh okay see you get to firing instincts
and partner of the game Awards and
throughout the night you'll be hearing
from my fellow Canadian lots of
Canadians tonight - tech tips about
Samsung's cue LED TVs optimized for the
best gaming experience take a look -
from - tech tips and I'll be talking
about some of the ways livingroom gaming
is better than ever when I was a case
about a chess player built into it not
very immersive with a samsung q LED TV
not only can you see more than ever
before but at 4k resolution with sizes
of up to 82 inches the image clarity is
unbelievable and with Samsung's 10-year
burnin guarantee you can game without
worry
[Music]
many people know me as a walk I am deaf
and I play fortnight and I'm 14 I was
just a streamer with and she's a she's
very young so she's got a long career
and incredible
I mean I've become the first woman in
faze clan my goal is to see many more
females playing and considered at an
equal level and I really want to see
she's not hindered by her disability
that she got mad skills like that that's
awesome
I love seeing stuff like that Kofi said
the first PlayStation 5 game announced
coming to PC as well Jackie was wrong
about that a stroke
Oh Jeff I'm excited to tell you that in
January magic will be returning to one
of our most beloved worlds so the last
time we went to Pharos a world of gods
myths and monsters we saw our hero
Elsbeth tyrell my favorite planeswalker
betrayed by the gods and banished to
walk the underworld but now our hero is
ready magic by death and escape her fate
sneak peek at what's in store for her
now with music by Ramin Djawadi this is
the trailer for tharros beyond death
alright check it out did anybody play
this with actual cards yep and I also
played the games on 360 as well I used
to play dude I had my decks were
ridiculous during the fourth generation
third fourth I missed the first but oh
yeah yeah magic is a very long running
card franchise and the gamers are
actually pretty good well we're pretty
good
see d-mac with a series xfig and a
normal TV stand wondering how toys
that's what I'm saying that the wall
unit imma have to sit it next to the
oscillating fan I'll just set it next to
IPC do these good job Magic the
Gathering
nerds yo there is nothing the idea by
magic Katherine sir and anyway you're a
gamer so you're a nerd I was about to
say that over here to gave advice you
know what someone just did what I know
they took I guess a screenshot of the
controller
apparently there's a share button on the
new Xbox controller because I am tired
of pressing the Xbox Live button and or
sign and it's they need it that's one
thing PlayStation always did right who's
that share its the chevrons great
[Music]
TC said I'm always petty even in the
hospital
all right the new game announcements
just keep rolling here at the game
eventually we'll get some games you
already know about but let's keep going
with things you haven't seen he's really
outdone herself this year
ya know III have to give him a
tremendous props great flow with the
with the show so far
some of the smaller announcements were
done on the side he's really outdone all
that's come be done done if that
straight it would gable yeah y'all gonna
be tight I'm gonna be honest with you
okay actually I I I'm so over dude I
mean it's I listen I think it should be
honestly I think it should be Sakura to
be honest what just happened yeah but
didn't show anything
Nakamura she's got good energy de
[Music]
English boxes now PC get that Xbox Xbox
joy in our brains and helps us to change
the way we think because I love that
accent we need to change it to survive
this your window statue just dropped an
article dude they obviously had the info
on because I'm here i'ma send you the DM
to this story you might want to use this
for Sunday show there's a quote from
Phil it
[Applause]
dropping it
[Music]
get it
yesterday today today now to one the
audio with the Kingdom Hearts isn't best
audio desire all it was home it was a
kick across and the veena is in that
article with all in engine footage yes
in game in engine yes what that was a
Wow no that's the game dude
Phil Spezza revealed the console stage
also showcases from the ground of a new
engine that look
[Applause]
we're dr. Singhal nut he looked like a
movie I wish you were you know what you
said something this is what they need to
keep doing this it's the president down
the boy has been say you see how I thank
you goes to the art director Yan nipple
King and he hears an amazing person he's
worked at remedy for a long while
Luiza crystal clear vision of what he
wanted to achieve with control and he
did amazing things together with his
team I also have to thank cert McDonald
who is the world design director 90 for
me how the characters and all the creepy
monsters that existed in this game and I
can't imagine a better group of artists
intelligent creative people to work with
and this is thanks to you guys thank you
so much
[Applause]
dr. all bodies the guys I wish I was
that bad but please don't workers
because it honor for the you know but
look at the venting on the time that's
how much heat is coming out this thing
bro but once that momentum happen or how
do we just lean that looks like a
persistent virtual place can be so
that's why even this year over 10
million people in it you know he says
here was built to maximize airflow and
it says he would support for both
vertical and horizontal orientations
none I understand mom's probably have
seen teasing a little bit about some of
this happening at risky reels tied to
Star Wars yeah yes yes and it's what can
you tell us about it you know I probably
can't tell you much but noise JJ thanks
Donald hey everyone it's JJ Abrams
director of the rise of Skywalker join
me in fortnight on Saturday for an
exclusive look at the movie to see the
whole thing you got to be in the game so
I'll see you in fortnight on Saturday
that's why fortnight's MVP that's why
I'm surprising
and I think you know some people online
it's like oh you're just running a
clipper what is the Arctic Ocean
separate it's gonna be a live
participatory experience right I think
it's gonna be like something yeah I'm
sorry man
yeah about sort of what this means I
think programming inside a games shared
experiences like the game words people
all coming together watching this but
this is inside the game world I'm really
excited about what is gonna happen on
Saturday right from the Game Awards to
that but before then I know you've got
some other some cool things that people
can pick up in fortnight we do so
there's one more thing so right now you
can go to fortnight and these are now
available and they're some of my
favorite characters of all time
[Music]
[Applause]
the star would probably approach bid not
be okay you'll we've luck to really do
we've got much more that's why I'm for
the epic game store tonight and this
next one comes from a team up in my home
country of Canada I keep mentioning
Canada but this is a game that's I think
you'll be surprised by and I saw it I
said hey this would be a cool thing to
announce the game warden so check it out
what are they going to end this show on
that's wrong
none of that like work we're leaving
before we go here you here's a woman
Australia
[Music]
miss def starting to
gosh lady Christine she says how does
the lockhardt fit into this series ex
God falls multi-player yeah sure said
PlayStation 5 in an epic still that's a
moat aqua only won't ask the new rules I
forgot you what is yo what is going on
here xbox ex new one what's what's going
on captain here
[Music]
I think this basically said hey there
was three things you drunk enough for my
hit there - oh Lord
but it's judgin lucky to say the Lord's
Day the forest interesting what's the
platform sons of the forest we got some
cool stuff tonight all right
well one of the most played games in the
world is League of Legends and tonight
it is we're happy to have riot and its
new riot forward with us to reveal their
first single player experience for the
franchise have they showed your stock if
you know let's go yes let's go show us
it League of Legends their new game long
oh come on
that's Thresh
Oh a thresher Lucien story we doing it
let def have this y'all already see
Thresh stole his wife what do you expect
oh I am I'm done with it let's go
educated it's uh
okay think he knows ruined King is this
character is a guy called Lucius and
Thresh stole assault
Ellucian exec for revenge before now but
we are doing the first-ever riot Forge
game as you saw it is the ruined King a
league of legends story experience a
good acidity a tweet look like a face
get a look at this right we have a new
take on turn-based combat that's really
cool obviously the visual art and
visuals that our studio is known for and
the story takes place after burning
tides so everyone believes gangplank is
dead yo Bilgewater
yep chaos and you'll actually play
League champions and explore Bilgewater
the shadow we better do something make
because they could be hard
right now thank you very much Joe back
yeah great announce with legal edges
that's okay I'm happy I'm very happy
cool good when we come back a
performance by Grimes the award for best
action game with Norman Reedus with
Norman Reedus early
[Music]
I said no come on Harley we've been here
I don't want to see no League of Legends
slender in the trip but you guys just
don't really birds of prey material no
offense
what I love you do suckers never quit
messing around let's give these people
what they want
ladies if you want boys to respect you
you have to show them that you serious
[Music]
oh we really don't know about this movie
together
she's got range
[Music]
especially hardly could you know
everyone wants to be a enough
[Music]
[Applause]
we got a system for you it's our only
exclusives at this points be off it
looks like yeah doom is such a good game
yeah there he is
I reckon dude I can kill kratos per
night oh thank you barely oh these
protest signs oh we can't read 2000 wait
no there's a ton of games in March
that's that's bad that's all yeah March
is crazy muff right yeah March is super
loaded
[Music]
[Music]
to stay in the light game all game what
sale let's get it
[Music]
my wife - how blade - looks amazing yes
it does alright music is a big part of
game Oh cyberpunk 2077 is one of the
most anticipated games coming out next
year
well hello to everyone at CD Projekt RED
they're over in Poland they're working
hard to finish the Polish brother right
now we've got a behind the scenes look
at the soundtrack this is where the game
best thing if it's true run the jewels
we're not here as refused we're here
samurai it's a very interesting thing to
be part of we really work on these songs
trying to make them as good as possible
I think my music fits with my city
because both are scary and pretty at the
same time 2077 I'm super excited
rebellious and it's quite noisy old I
think Industrial is the word I can't
wait to see how your two-year-olds
actually there are some people that are
saying that their game of the year
already
it is the time the games like everybody
at CD Projekt RED like always high that
helps to create a process I'm alright
what kind of do his Isis blaze this hell
they broke the video blind with the Lord
they invited lock that for that
exclusive never forget yeah cuz I'm your
probably high let me guess I think to
settle down attics oh no man a kiss
check this egg ready
I can't steer I'll push six delicate
magical thickness oh there's more wood
Oh what do $60 games on it
[Music]
well backs I want you
[Music]
not gonna lie though
told you man it sounds like everyone's
hot
[Music]
dudas I'm looking at Twitter it's nice
to see people were changing their minds
a lot Xbox like they really are yeah you
want to laugh or you wanna laugh cog
Mike Bates you know he's always in your
chat he says I love but I almost fell
out of my office
I want to replay this and listen to us
react shout out the undead already got a
piece of the game today
I don't wanna be and then um David Lee
in a pejorative said we're just getting
started
I told you dude you have to be on some
acid to understand this scum flow you
know how like Kojima's way down like I
don't understand think this is like on
the adjacent opposite end event
[Music]
Citians we did oh I think this yes
cyberpunk music okay I'm doing with that
thing with that soap you know there it
is
let's get it day one easier already
pre-ordered put in the bushes in it's
time to present the award for best
action game here we go these games are
all widely wildly different so I do I
compare I just don't think he deserves
that but the one thing they have in
common is that one set the bar for
lively combat and thrills all right yeah
[Applause]
- okay thank you papa
oh I pulled my hair I'm down on my sword
that I don't my sword had to change they
go in
yes I really want Kate to win this I
want Kate he is five and the winner is
Devil May Cry Wow if I was the fantastic
a man you have not played it shame on
you two big thing is I am I am shocked
without was stiff competition as double
Vic has this [ __ ] won an award yet
they won one yet one what what works so
far David I think so yeah a conscious
must do income Mata Greta
they will make right she didn't know one
Lumias on hey thank you so much for all
the fans we've been supporting us and
thank you so much for waiting eleven
years for the sequel what's uni massugu
knee action game Antonio optimist oh
you're right boss is really trying to
make as pure of an action game as
possible you know what this means it is
it's good that it won if you're a family
series I mean the Capcom's gonna stick
with this mythic they'll be a secret
there'll be a staff calling fun to come
back stories
no they will bet they were almost ready
to file bankruptcy know that this to be
elite and founder of two games from
Canada I don't know how it all works out
that way but a lot of Kent
Grimes Canadian Jeff all right anyways
tell us what you were working on up at -
thanks Jeff I'm super excited to be here
with the world premiere of the game
we've been working on up in Montreal sad
newton moment when we started working on
this game we we had the idea to put
action back in action RPG and what
better place than in Dungeons & Dragons
Forgotten Realms icewind dale slay
together with your friends I'm super
pleased to announce Dungeons & Dragons
Dark Alliance oh ok a new dungeons at
rapid game up and I'm with it dependent
they said they were gonna have something
let's have a look see what they do
you say I could smash game already
looking better than this train good song
choice I don't know if this is a Diablo
style game or just
as a dope song for this tell mm-hmm
great choice
Oh
dungeons at Jackie's dock a lot y'all
I'm Dave yeah okay 2020 is stacked it's
the best year in gaming
I'm telling it all right up next is the
award for the it's the most looks like
it's mirage everybody what's up mirage
hey Kili my man what's going on well
we're kind of in the middle of the game
Awards right now but yep what's going on
oh is that tonight tell me tell me did
they already win for best all-around
competitor in a battle royale based on
skills but mostly good looks that is
such a specific award as I told you on
Twitter does not exist
oh okay okay I see what you're doing
keeping the mystery alive for the
audience I get it it's a secret award I
get later wink it's not like I haven't
been practicing my acceptance speech wow
these things are really heavy um I'd
like to thank my mother for my
exceptional
Mirage we have a show we've got lots of
announcements to get to see this is like
okay cringe to knees always reach what
it's a fun cringe is that I'm here
tonight to just give the people what
they want and chilli chilli check this
out this is so cool watch he's actually
one game and he's the kind of dude you
would hang
oh yeah it's my big holiday bash you get
it hollow days cuz the and I do Holly
Graham Singh
anyway can I put you down for a plus-one
fine when does it start Mirage oh that's
the best part this party wait for it
starts right now celebrating the game
yogiraj is probably one of the best
characters join me at the party and you
all get this free exclusive legendary
skin of my matching g7 a Prague thank
you yeah extremely generous of you
Mirage thank you for what can I say Jeff
I am a giver all right well I listen up
we do have a show to to you know get
back to so thanks brush
okay okay best buddy can't wait to see
you and everything it's party time
everybody's using my xbox sex dance
table to the Jupiter 2 you should you
should get a t-shirt maybe put there put
down the family forget around bubble
bubble this is what overwatch toast
they'd be prettier on the second map
right now okay
but I feel like that kind of hurdle they
started off with all this tremendous
momentum I just wanted them to continue
it no I think they still got the
momentum leave you doing quite a lot of
things I mean I'll take it over
fortnight anything
well fortnight has the bigger things as
well like the Star Wars the Infinity
Gauntlet
you know because it's clearly not as big
as fortnight but yeah it's this better
than I'll be real with you I'm not
looking forward to its not hate it's
just not my type of thing great dude you
know we're old-school like that card we
remember we remember Sunday and you know
if you if you know what we're talking
about you at Sunday used to be the dog
we used to catch all those films channel
5 that search
the little sexy food hockey game with
powers yeah we're here with it we're to
forte he must have passed out with her
did the sex title yeah but covers it's
too much he let it all out there
he spent from Xbox and Moon Studios
here's a brand new look at or are you a
boys do you think we get a release date
yep it's yep nice see or either easy
coughing pepper no games come and egg
really grand metal
it is I mean 2020 is probably gonna be
the best year in game in there is I mean
you know multiple consoles we don't know
if switch is gonna come out with or with
a pro you know that there's rumored for
that you have you know you have two main
consoles you have all these games I mean
think about justjust if no other games
released but what we're talking about
west of us you must decipher from
unknown and witty quote and hallo -
hallo - II don't need any other game but
then if you had tomorrow the other game
oh they moved it too much they could
take all the time they want on that game
you know it's create a game that game
looks like Game of the Year quality and
it's and it's not manly to get up a nod
because it's just it's just so static
when it comes to upping your competition
level there's no doubt that more frames
per second makes a measurable difference
trust me
that's why samsung's latest cue LED tvs
you know what the best TVs in a market
dude when you're gaming and turns off
any extra image property beget a second
[Laughter]
least I got a good dad before we can
even embrace our loved ones beat them
our fireteam leader says do not tell
anybody what happened to you or what you
saw or what you experienced
who said another Xbox gamer you see
stack up as a military charity
supporting us and allied veterans mental
health in gaming overwatch is our newest
program and it is simply having a chat
client up somebody comes in and says
they need to talk or they're interested
to get into a point of doing old-school
and you you know that's all about yes
yes yes yes get those big TVs you need
three people to have lips what there was
always a 13-inch TV mm-hmm you remember
the GX TV here's the silliness like this
I don't know yeah you know people games
for impact but first I was hoping - oh
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so glad you're here wearing VR
goggles to demonstrate our brand new you
can put them on but you can't get them
off what are we calling it
of course the untitled beaker game
excellent choice
let the game begin
[Applause]
I love this guy I love that game house
house hilarious
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ready Leon oh well here are the nominees
for games for impact
recognizing socially conscious and
progressive leaders in the industry role
the nominees I see good shows like the
strange for this
again want me to beat this hotel
[Music]
how long is the game Wars is it three
hours yeah because we're going on we're
going on the game awards didn't start
till nine yeah it didn't start on the
first hour was it was the the warm-up
show okay 8:00 8:30 to 9:00 with the
warm-up would you please holy did you
play it Oh goose it's one of the biggest
VMs all right yeah the award for games
for impact goes to no not these briefs
it's coming into game yes I think
yeah there's coming good
addict nobody voted for this one you
know the Lord's all wrong
yep one vote which would life is strange
yeah a goose it's common to be in cars
yes it is indeed one of the biggest
gains in 2019 believe it or not with
first of all congratulate the director
with all the team
back at home we made a really good team
and we could have never made it without
them to thank the bulbar for allowing us
to I wanted to make I mean I would like
to thank especially to all those people
that share their stories with us they
send they say moving stories where they
were playing Greece that's something
that obviously when you create again you
try to do these kind of things but you
never know you're going to get to
someone and we pretty much are so move
when you're when we receive this story
so please keep sharing it with us
because it's amazing and thank you
everybody that playing super Greece
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right sorry thanks to Bunsen and
beaker lifelong dream to have them here
at the show all right I also want to
mention something called the game
festival I know if you heard about that
online but we're launching a new tie to
the game where it's called the game
festival and the around the world who
watch the show you watch trailers you
love games a chance to play a bunch of
games and this year we're partnering
with steam and if you head to steam for
the next 48 hours a little bit less than
that since it started this morning we
have first looked demos of over a dozen
upcoming games that you can play for
free on Steam and I think that's kind of
the future where this all goes is not
necessarily these local events where you
have to travel somewhere to play a game
but actually bringing games into your
homes and and the places you work and
live to play so play it all those games
the game festival concludes Saturday at
10 a.m. Pacific and next year we're
gonna do it across all the platforms so
it's gonna be a big thing so we're
dealing more with that presents more
Awards and let's get into the best
family game the nominees for that 10
degrees okay
which is the best Nintendo game he said
he hurried world kind of like Nintendo's
chances in this category Luigi's Mansion
category a best sports racing game for
the best traditional and non-traditional
sports racing game those nominees are
Crash Team Racing nitro fuel slash truth
the game where it's FIFA twenty two
point II football Pro Evolution Soccer
2020 f1 2019 and FIFA 20 and the game
award goes to crash team white that's a
shocker that's a shock the nominees are
Call of Duty mobile grindstone sayonara
Wildhearts we announced last year play
my wild tops is actually pretty cool
what the Gulf and the game award in that
category goes to Call of Duty mobile
congratulate
these guys alright well now I'd like to
welcome the co-creators of dishonored
and pray Ralph and Julian are here you
may have seen online that they just
announced their brand new studio wolf I
inset here at the game orange they were
gonna reveal their first game so guys
welcome to the game wardens you've been
here before
you've got this new studio so tell me a
bit about wolf Isle
what's different about it so we took a
long break but it looks like we can't
stay away from Michael Jackson
interesting worlds to explore we have
passion for depth of interactivity and
of course the attempts to show you
through a teaser and we're very excited
it's amazing one of my favorite players
talked his way as well no problems with
their bed during the development process
devolver did so land of opportunity the
place where you can be here
scoundrel quite the Wild West as you
know there are $18 at war look crazy
strange entities lurking in the dead of
night with their own welcome the
weirdest okay
it's an RPG dishonored right involve a
abacab those doubt the wrong with this
little building there's like a whole
body top Borderlands with some action
RPG elements okay so it's got the
traditional RPG camera angle I'm with it
alright that's a brand new MMO action
RPG game from a legendary franchise
check out this announcement ooh a new
MMO world premiere come on give me a
good
okay okay I'm with this
right
all right color representation I'm happy
[Laughter]
all right we don't get a lot of those
protagonist min we got it we got a shout
out fantasy magic okay good okay
your dissipate yogi says fables Vegas
but what kind of MMO is it
oh yeah at a brand-new game from an
exciting new studio Awards you Congress
tell you guys you can place probably
mrs. booms to get through the jungle
cats Christmas oh yeah yeah that's
exactly what it's like the stadium no
performance targets 30 frames per second
no I just want you to know they spent
more on this commercial and stadiums
main commercial dude
[Applause]
when pop G mobile one of the biggest
video games in the world and global
green a world renowned non-profit
partner to help save the Amazon we
challenged people across the globe to
stand together and fight to protect our
planet you might have stepped away and
the Amazon is critical to protecting us
from the devastating of what happened to
Forte he went to a store to pre-order we
heard the sex was too much for you it
was I had to go I had to go get this
video I started doing voiceover real
quick why I have a 1 to make no because
Microsoft had to make me want to do
anything I saw that I was like oh I
gotta talk there we go right there I you
know what I wish they wouldn't let us
not free water I want that [ __ ] paid off
in advance
[Music]
yeah you know that's what are they
sources does it to drop a new shoe Smash
Brothers ultimate character today I
don't think we can take any more
Microsoft stuff could you imagine if it
was Master Chief but it's roomier and on
my scream all about helping my viewers
accomplish their goals whether it's
making progress in gaming fitness or
just taking control their health in
general and if one of your goals is the
quick vaping truth is a program that can
help
it's called business quitting it's free
anonymous text-based available any time
of day run on your phone and it's
already helping thousands of people quit
I have to do is take the ditch jewel to
7:09 join the program I've been here
this whole time I didn't care about it
so I went and watched a press start
water and stadium large commercial was
going on oh here we go
ocular quest I'm already studio ok I'm
going back to press load
[Music]
or - that
I'm buying this is available right down
there would a hell yeah dude
[Music]
one of the most-watched
and the winner of last year's game award
for content free
Karina please welcome ninja bang mm-hmm
hello everyone thank you guys so much
for obviously being here I've been
playing video games my entire life
and there's something magical about a
solo player experience and the only way
to enhance that is to play games with
your friends I've literally defined my
entire career by playing online
multiplayer games we do the rest
multiplayer game of year whatever we
have a ninja now to call it Uli's
project
we know with not winning me but they
know we added it's now oh yeah I think
all right the game award for best
multiplayer game goes to oh it's a lot
more difficult to open up than you think
[Applause]
how many awards is love you know what
you have to give this game credit for
besides being really really fantastic
game is how they kept this thing secret
yo this came all the team that stuck
around and believed and made this magic
happen thank you to the fans thank you
so much
what's to you guys just for the team
that research you know why it is easy
for super talented individuals makes we
changed our genre the most important
developer place you not using so Thank
You Man games how they want to do it and
winning which is technically against
EA's philosophies all the stuff yeah
they represent and
winning so now they're so involved in
life I love this all right well I
congratulate he's the same year that
store was the match weeks fans have been
celebrating gaming and 50 million video
views so far tonight you can use the
hashtag on tik-tok to join the
celebration of gaming and eSports
biggest night in the contest too cheesy
c64 he's the guy that want it right
there so congratulations to him all
right we've got so much more Game Awards
coming up the gaming on tick tock
contest will continue for the next few
days cheesy c64 the next twitch poll is
open for best ongoing game you can go
vote now and we'll see who you think is
going to take home the game award in
general but right now let's talk about a
big PlayStation 4 title that's coming
next year go from the guys it's smoke
punch goes up to SEMA you probably saw
this tease earlier this week I am so
excited about this game what Sucker
Punch is bringing to life we have our
longest world premiere in the show
tonight as I've been saying a true
cinematic look enjoy that ghost Ashima
and let's see we've got what is this
Ashima I'm really looking forward like
I'm really looking into this game this
game looks amazing day one yeah
I still need to be sold on that soon
let's understand it well they haven't
really showed a whole whole lot on that
one trailer since I'm into my tent shoes
and my samurai bra so I need them to
show me this is a you turn into a ninja
in this game yep we go from the samurai
and this was that old feudal Japan show
me the combat the boot dude that he Adam
so Jeff really outdid himself this might
be the best Game Awards I think in the
haze of the actual Awards I think a navy
awards at all let's go they're not
showing the combat though yeah I mean
it's I'd love to see it to be honest
this looks an engine right all right
yeah it is this is probably in game we
got detention jump from the top let's go
this is tension vines over
wow this is really good this is the
spiritual successor to tenchu then it
really does give you the 10/2 vibe sure
[Music]
[Laughter]
no tension so legendary is still mom's
good inertia meruna
[Music]
this is gonna be one of those games that
you find yourself taking hundreds of
pictures call el mil how do not impress
this buyer day one when a they had that
fight with the cherry blossoms remember
that first yes when it has the samurai
fight with the cherry blossom I was like
this date fine yeah anytime you got
cherry blossoms in your game if they're
all quiet there at the end worth oh yes
this looks really good
and considering sucker-punch hasn't made
anything since 2014
okay that is root man the sequel let's
cop it makes sense this time the
question is do they release this or do
they save this for ps5 this come on
Ritchie the release dates coming right
here oh I hope so
no it's a bangle of food man's in the
building when is it no summer summer
okay that's getting the way I've worried
if they can't give us a defined date its
kindling
no you know what I mean I mean listen
it's got to come out before the pool but
they also have to give the list but I'm
thinking maybe August August if this
game comes out let's get right before
the holiday there best of the game
[Applause]
celebrating our game of the Year
nominees and game of the year will be
presented by some very special guests
surprise guest so stay tuned for that
but right now we've got another world
premiere oh here we go here we go yes
let's go kids
[Music]
let's get it give me that released ain't
good for us so we did the only thing we
could we set the world on fire
mmm-hmm tactics my war begins against
these monsters lovers
let's go really state give us it it's
time to go hunting
let's go gummy backs
[Applause]
see what my newest creation drinks of
the orange a forty-hour - oh nice okay
you meet some campaign
let's go this will hold me over until
XCOM 300k let's turn back to twitch we
asked hours to come an Xbox final
fantasy xiv we will find out when we
present that award a little bit just for
right now a performance that's gonna
rock the house by Green Day let's go no
you can't stand outside here is I gotta
go
I used to miss it the Green Day but they
look old no don't pick up Greendale my
little build it is no power greater I
see you girl I don't know
[Music]
see what's this yeah that was go back in
the play today footage captured in gay
okay okay I'm very blossom so it's
already they already gave you a cherry
bomb okay this combat looks nice yeah
fix that frame rate okay everything oh
this is much this is more tensions and
this is tension like hundred twenty
frames all this I this looks fantastic
making this rohnke Chevy blossoms off oh
oh
welcome to magic school he announced
that before it came flying let's talk
about giant oh not to be confused with
bird people bird people are their own
thing play Magic the Gathering down the
favorite was Barbara illusion
how many years have I waited for this
moment for the one city road alone
against the storm for the one they
called
oh we get a new expansion no we can't
cuz they just will be shadow bringers
it's called Naraka
and a are aka it just says 2020
[Music]
I'm pulling up the information right now
yeah I'm gonna need that deafening great
game on character playing this is
fantastic it's essentially a this is a
single-player game it's brilliant
yeah it's called na ra ka apparently
it's it's it's it's from next yeah it's
called it from Nettie's games 24
entertainment okay what's the name of it
rocker late for a blade point let me see
if I can find him on Twitter the doctors
call it a major depressive episode that
game was fantastic completely out of
nowhere - that's that's a that's you
know that that's a dope world cuz you
don't expect something like that please
welcome Sidney Goodman
[Applause]
I'm here to present the award for best
ongoing game recognizing that we keep
playing our favorite games year after
year and acknowledging the teams that
keep these massively popular franchises
fresh with new content more experiences
and evolving ways to play here are the
nominees best ongoing game
all right Todd neo just our last chance
right here Loki as much as I was a
vestige of it we we had our fun I think
this is they gave that to us systems let
us down here there's our last chance to
win something when the awards are
actually on the game award for best
ongoing game goes to fortnight yeah this
is the power
[Applause]
anybody anybody didn't think for tonight
was gonna run this
[Applause]
did you know what throw jokes aside the
way they innovate with that game I know
people hate on it because I read the
play but they don't sit on their hands
with that game do so like last year we
represent just like the tiniest portion
of the now over a thousand people who
work to make fortnight something and
that is incredible every single day and
you know we're just so humbled
constantly to have the opportunity to
even make something like for tonight
it's incredible I think that a you know
as I was saying earlier right like this
idea that we need to lean into what a
persistent virtual place can be and the
more that we're trying to experiment
with stuff and try different things
we're finding more and more that our
goal is to try to create a Metaverse to
create a place right where we're all IP
can live together where all kinds of
experiences can happen where we can
create a thing that is totally new a
totally new emergent type of media
really and we are so inspired by
everything you're doing I'm just blown
away by what we see here tonight it's
it's it's truly astounding and
incredible thank you for all the work
you do thank you for all the people who
play for at night no prob what the
advertiser says for the new Xbox
x-series X fastest their tagline is
fastest
and mostly dude that's right on the
front cover could be a method behind the
madness as far as why the deviled eggs I
worked on Max Payne this was the biggest
power move of 29px box
[Music]
how about if when I play it but I got a
[Music]
respected let's get this job down to
five interesting there you go that's
nine to five and I'm here with red Hill
games CEO Mattias Matthias great to have
you with us
what is nine to five what can we expect
thank you Jeff glad to be here nine to
five is a new first-person tactical
shooter it's set in a world where
corporations rule everything and being a
mercenary is just another job now a lot
of modern shooters can be a little bit
chaotic and that's kind of what makes
nine-to-five special we really put a lot
of focus on the strategic gameplay of
the team and playing together and you
know making your changes in your tactics
from round to round and obviously all
that triumphs over brute force at the
end all right when can we expect to hear
more next year or so 2020 we're
launching the Alpha but you can actually
sign up today at 9 to 5 dot game so go
ahead enjoy and download all right a
little bit of a tease 9 to 5 all right
thanks very much for being go fast
appreciate gonna hand out some more
Awards right you know I got to tell you
the flow of the show is so improved over
the last it's I mean I know I know
people you know like yes some people may
say all the muppet thing I actually got
the mother Dingell funny yeah of course
you know I gotta tell you beats Avery is
so it is dope dope dope on Skye I didn't
get a chance to tell you Joe did you
hear what's will me hood did for me
[Applause]
you know you are between overwhelming
gunshot Laura Bailey four gears five if
Kate win I'll be bad don't get Nicholson
for death stranding actually you can do
it strum them come on man he's a good at
a lot of you around the world voted
tournament-style to pick your favorite
game this was a hundred percent in
control of the fans inner of the fan
vote is I would've liked Jedi to get
incredible stories yeah Jedi I should
have got three houses I didn't play it I
hurt everyone that recognizing this
year's class is I think it's almost game
yes yes Damon Percival what did AMD
tweets wishes
congratulations guys
beautiful a selfie alright we're so
proud of that program we intend to
continue that year after year I love
telling all these stories of amazing
people around the world who I think
represent gaming at its best all right
up next we've got music from Green Day
Orchestra and the big award game of the
year presented by some special guests
now the popular action MMORPG black
desert has only been available for PC
and console but now black desert mobile
is available on iOS and Android you can
download it tonight and get a true
MMORPG at your fan everything is going
on mobile dude
[Music]
jasio because bats can't come I was
proposed to bro
[Music]
who you wanted the girl from outer world
dude I use of the whole game yep I
couldn't take her out of my party
yeah she was in she was in the party
literally from the time up dad you get
her to the end of the game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know I was prepping to say in-game
bash
[Music]
sure to stay in the light game would say
you're still poppin they're probably
your weekend
let's say you're not the super
competitive type and you're more about
that eye candy a samsung q LED TV has
got when it comes to the most i popping
visuals HD are you what is the way to go
dude quantum dot technology delivers
amazing color fidelity while full array
local dimming allows the brightest and
darkest parts of the scene to look their
best features like these are why samsung
q LED TV was a best of innovation
honoree for gaming at CES 2019 and
they're nominated again for 2020 I
didn't think anybody was really gonna
play this game we got over a half a
million letters written in the first
couple months which just we were not
prepared for kind words is a game about
writing nice letters to people all real
people anonymously online sharing their
worries what making each other feel
better pushing the definition of the
games is something that I've really get
excited about
maybe I have control over people sending
random letters to each other that can
get messy contractually but you know the
internet the way the internet there the
way internet slided be able to watch
your random stuff
a mobile game or is this a Nintendo
switch game
[Music]
ee deep-black fine-tuned performance
I think he's got statue to buy he needs
campus one of these Black Friday my
ability to win one of the WD blacks WT
blacks good drive here yeah radians
[Music]
we are excited to welcome WD black to
the game wars is the official storage
sponsor all of tonight's world premiers
have been safely stored on WD black an
get command performance with SSD speed
check out WD black comm for a chance to
win a decked out gaming rig and WD black
products all right now I'm very excited
to introduce our next performance one of
my passions outside of gaming is live
music whenever I go to I'm always
thinking about who would be perfect here
for the game
know about that
Bulevar the broken dreams is their last
good so and to know about that they're
not as good as they used to be
the lymphedema no no no disrespect
No Green Bay College we said Green Bay
is darkness you that real UK create
Queen they used to be good nope never
happening
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for the dunk
did you handsome put their hands up
that's right respect your elders
always this is in the bushes she's got
is something look at that look at that
God he's standing up for the cars
the only way to make that face below get
your goddamn hands up in the air damn
race is amazing come on soon racer
[Music]
dumb boy can't do that right get that
move right there young boy can't move
around too much when all the 40 wards
[ __ ] cool emo kids in school you know
your pops is banging this brightness up
got this right there you act like I
didn't listen to Green Day
our skillset uh-huh
I will say the same thing I said to the
food yeah get the people in there Zimmer
frames apostate
[Music]
right ed to take the youth tonight this
is homework overs day yeah these bars
out here don't look I'm pulling my bar
for dreams there we go bilingual album
three hours let's go Green Day now you
want to serenade people on the stage
let's go Michael
does have my jacket
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
since you gotta tell the truth you know
you do that crimp somebody go down
thank you John seat Jonathan agrees with
me Jonathan be fair to you
Thank You the water finger
[Music]
they'd be gone Finney eagle in the
charters mr. new album I got our support
no another ten years at or green thing
is like the Nintendo Damon no Green Day
is the Google studying
[Music]
no this is tender gladly Tendo classic
right here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
please no more schools what if they run
off like that the degree okay I
appreciate the green is my favorite
color but no educator y'all used to do
no you'll notice a dream day the clap
we've always wanted and you don't have
to wait some good music I want to see
you screaming if I don't see you
streaming up seven thank you so much of
course you got the award for best game
direction
we've got game of the year and yes we've
still got some announcements and some
prizes for you guys at gaming's biggest
night it just gets bigger and bigger
running all around the world and we've
got another world premiere for you to
check out right now
enjoy
it is an eternal island of legend a
place of unimaginable beauty or in
constant conflict damn what games this
er hmm I'm like anesthetic raspberry oh
[ __ ] okay
go ahead look like Raj the little people
it does look like dog this is rise to
its foes alike
the rule is ever a look to what the rise
could probably
no-limit right this release lured by the
promise of power and immortality the
darkness will claim
you willed some day I have of my eyes on
Laswell a couple months ago I had a
great time playing it and it looks
really cool and you can get more info at
new world.com all right well now please
welcome to the stage a good friend of
the game Awards
he's been here every year since the
first show with a perfect attendance
record of course he's the former
president Nintendo of America again
but already
[Applause]
I'm too permanent now
[Applause]
fisa Mac is in the house thank you thank
you thank you for that warm welcome it
was just over 16 years ago that I joined
this industry as an executive but truth
be told I've been around as a fan and as
a player for so much longer dominus
fingers and Reggie disappeared do games
continue to innovate not only as
entertainment but also into areas far
more profound experiences with their
foundation in video game does our being
that's that that's the me and to enable
college students to simulate business
situations and develop real-world skills
I may no longer be an executive in this
industry but I'll always be an
ambassador go to bed Joe Barresi
as a force for good and a force for fun
[Applause]
in this category fresh indie game you
can see how games are continuing to
evolve guys entertainment I think they
went into it I'm gonna be honest with
you because I believe indie developers
are the most important creators in this
industry every nominee this year and
every year at one time was an indie
developer in the same sense that
everyone was once a kid sketching a
superhero in the middle of class or
lying in bed at night Mego who's got the
tickets to Star Wars next week already
there next Thursday baby yeah yeah
Thursday at the 1930 at 7:00 p.m. first
show in his house my brother hooking up
with free tickets cuz of his company got
a parted friends whatta those ideas led
him to invent his first video game on a
portable calculator while he was still
in high school
they both became fixtures in the history
of video games but first they were
dreamers and they began with their
imagination so like everyone else at the
start they were true indie developers
its rewards event is by definition a
look backwards who's done something
great in the preceding year but in this
category you can look forward if you
want to see the incubator where future
game record is evolving light resides
right here in this indie category
recognizing brand new independent
studios who released their first game
this year they showed already fresh
indie game presented by subway
wrong
front page for a while strong
[Music]
stay the spire
good skin old coat and pow yeah come on
subway drop the bag it's the biggest
title goose Kane comes to console people
thank you you know what is they probably
didn't expect to win anything yeah you
know what I'm saying
nominated the competition that they're
going up against is tremendous I've been
looking back what's it my whole life
that's my family oh my friends my son
they say you can't change a person but
can change with time change your mind
change a heart sites gonna oh it's mica
legends get a single player for leader
legends really though
yeah that's echo the guy everyone's time
oh okay another story okay so we get to
oh that looks interesting man I'm not a
bit I'm not a legal League of Legends
player but that looks that looks
interesting yeah boy double stallion
games Lee Thomas Lee why do you tell us
a bit about what we just saw
sure well that was quite an experience
so yeah we're here it's been an amazing
time keeping this secret but we are
working with Roy at forge making
convergence and League of Legends story
so what is it it's a single player
action platformer where you play echo
echo is a young inventor who has created
a device that can manipulate time I'm
gonna send you down into the depths of
the Sun and we're gonna deliver a rich
story experience about perils and close
on this you can kinda mess things up
huge consequences hugely great to have
you here great announcement all right in
just a moment five of the nominees for
game of the year are going to go
head-to-head in the best game Direction
category we'll see who wins the hello
man I'm enjoying it but happy with these
League of Legends announcements link is
getting some shine late leaves from
screen just try those stories single
place on our I will try the super player
storagee for the men of mobile guy but I
do love to layer this selfish experience
as I don't know like wait faced with the
amount of story in their essays so
really
yeah a gift that gives you beans they
got so many stories they could tell
and anyway well you know when we say
like these new science new science
school we do well you I could see them
continuing the trend
[Music]
well they need all the help they can get
[Laughter]
[Music]
No oh my god somebody I gotta put this
in the chat what somebody putting the
Twitter oh here Nintendo switch has
wolves to explore and adventures to come
[Music]
Oh put it in there check it out Wow look
at it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
I just can't I can't with these peoples
with
he'll take a live update it was a time
when you were heartless well we're
getting a little late in the late let
the show I don't know if we're getting
Batman I'm gonna be dama be mad as hell
[Music]
no more Green Day please oh yeah
let's go that looks good too
yes there it is number two they've been
talking about it for a while that was it
that wasn't that was in heavy
development before they went on an
accomplished voice actor please welcome
Ashley birch
hey this is Jeff robots
yeah I got my screen the best games
start with a single person asking a
single question yeah you can hear it
yeah start asking what if it's a
snowball of creativity and passion that
pushes games to be the best they can
possibly be these are the nominees for
the best game Direction best game
Direction troll hasn't won anything yet
so big man move connection
yeah
I'm also president to that sector Oh
another one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we want to thank a lot of people started
the ship going Sony started out with us
and also guerilla for providing the game
engine and also it was a small boat but
all the casts came on board the
musicians the artists the people and
best of all the fans who waited for
years thank you so much so far it's won
three awards
like 1/3
congratulations today we've got one more
award to present game of the year and
we've got some very special surprise
guests here to do the honors over on
Twitter you guys voted for the gaming
tweet of the year we've got the winning
you know what I think sector a wins it
man could be honest I think re2 is gonna
snuck it it's our listen I I'm alright
with that because I game in the year
because if the golden joystick sorry to
when they're so I'm beginning beginning
to think this is the year of re to after
that our e3 trailer all dragons I'm in
Oh
it is my game yep
Wow I played I played this game for four
years
still playing such a brick
open a therm is the name of the older oh
they're announcing the next DLC
Oh what is it yep very skyriver yes
staring and finally Skyrim the hold of
it yes
January 16th okay undo because they they
bought elsewhere
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh reeling
I'll have a new game
[Music]
now filly they got a whole bunch of
regions because they added morrowind
they've added elsewhere in their ad in
Skyrim then Nick they they've still got
a turnover map if you look at the map in
the game they got at least another like
four years worth of expansions they know
India done because the world of Elder
Scrolls is massive
okay
[Music]
now Philly they've still produced still
six regions and accounted for in the old
schools world so Elder Scrolls six will
probably cover one of the regions they
confirm God Paul pf5 launch pad arrived
okay yeah that looks good man I gotta
give them credit
I don't imagine he'll play too it's
gonna be an Xbox launch title it
different very where it could very well
be because I've been saying this for a
while and I've heard from different
sources I don't have big sources but I
heard that that game is whatever they
were working on before we knew it was
hell-blade to was in development a lot
longer than they're they're willing to
admit so it could very well be a launch
title for the you know obviously for the
sex box for the sex box if you look at
it you'll have hopefully to halo insulin
for tomorrow I think it is yes yeah if
there's no way they miss it there's just
no way yes yeah halo incident will be
dis ready big listen they can't miss
this monster no allow me to present the
world premiere of our latest expansion
to the Fast and Furious saga ok
one expansion is it for the walk game
only for speed beat I think I know
someone who can help
oh it's just a fuss in a furious game
but she said expansion so where is Terry
[Applause]
wish my mother woke up hey man I won't I
don't want this on my xbox go Tyrese
rubbers además don't get excited for
this oh it's this all the film is my big
once is he was in the back of the school
bus with a coca-cola commercial
operations to go about there okay I
guess can we can we at least use the
four is the engine to make like it looks
like ps2 you know what you now introduce
a surprise guest and also one of my
friends for life
Keanu Reeves please be gentle Reeves no
[Applause]
brother okay I like
[Applause]
oh I hope you like dessert the boot
extra I was extra two seconds too long
Vincennes family so much good party
do not tell me we are in our crowd
we have been gamers we have been gamers
forever and we are at an award show of
our people spend all night playing like
- Ken fighter games or a street fighter
yeah this is it's amazing to see that
that trailer finally I gotta tell you a
secret - I didn't tell you yesterday I
saw the moving trailer - fastener that's
how I caught you guys I love all of you
okay
here to pay tribute to all of the
nominees for game of the year hit once
again the Game Awards orchestra music
all the games
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh God would you pick on the IOP you
pick Sakura
[Music]
there's let this ball
I actually pick second okay
[Music]
you know that's that Tyros we we just
let it sit the title screen right there
[Music]
people tend oh here we go in a desk or
you're fired
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bars
[Music]
ours
oh really trying to put this down right
now which I'll let you know
at all
[ __ ] someone in the mixer chat who said
he's better than Green Day easy
[Music]
Oh balloons inability this is bull right
here old man I'm singing for Reza he
with two
turn up
they workplace
[Music]
speaking of girls they never showed
anything of Eldon ring no and they
didn't as my daughter would say dad take
over your fear and the game of the Year
award
yes sir Oh were you the only one that
picked it now let me ask you something
it is is this an epic upset no sleeping
giant valve I do this game was he
corrected bow bro
[Applause]
this is a perfect game show yeah no you
know what's funny
[Music]
difficult and complex elements that made
us a little unsure I'm gonna be tuning
in on Sunday to see you take that trophy
I have to say this might have been the
best show in this is the best show in
the last five years serves yeah yeah I
think that the way the show started with
the Xbox Xbox and hell-blade except the
president of huge thank you to our
players we couldn't have done it without
you and it was a huge honor to make so I
could to try and make me mad about SEC
Rio winning this because that game was
another game that you really okay
you're digging that stupid he said
update two ball Jeff gets removed from
the game
Game of the Year for Sakura alright guys
well that's gonna do it for the game or
its 2019 thank you so much for joining
or they go to the pressure control
didn't win anything okay that was a very
good game award show
I have to admit to the fantastic [ __ ]
expensive showing up and shedding for me
the legends for showing up I would have
to agree with you on that this was
probably the I agree with forte but I'm
gonna take it a bit further I think this
might be the the best show that they've
ever put on I mean come on I mean what
could you say the sex box and heavily to
confirmation I mean you know it's it's I
mean first of all you know it is it's
pretty epic when you think about how
Phil Spencer comes up on the stage now
as Xbox fans more more so as content
creators who cover the Xbox we have been
saying for quite some time that we
needed as fans fulfilled to do exactly
what he did today and he went up there
and in completely unbelievably shocking
from fashion showed off the next Xbox
console and even dropped the name you
know what I'm saying and what's crazy is
it apparently there's more that there's
more to show at that system but like
they showed the controller and we know
that the controller has a share button
now there is so much about this system
that has changed because of fan feedback
and like I said this looks like a
legitimate rig yes yes
definitely no definitely meant any other
little in the corner games that you got
your eye on that all I'm with you I like
nikana rocker blade point looks
fantastic new world looks very
interesting um let's see what else I got
here for me personally I think God fool
looks insanely incredible yes 5 ps4
launch title and guess what ghost
so Shima did not disappoint
that game looks like and I'm not sure
who said it but it looks like tenchu the
way you've always wanted it to be that
was me with the tension okay yeah that
was a good call on it because it did
give you the I mean at least for me
anyway I loved tenchu and it gave me
those vibes he's ever done I mean
highlights has to be Xbox and there has
to be hella blade and then the amount of
legal legends love those single prayers
look higher I mean there was a samurai
samurai game that was and ghosts about
ghosts there was fast
samurai game loved the combat definitely
always on that that was Game Awards
three hours long demos they recorded
three hours of gameplay can I have it
all on my computer and I'm gonna chop
that up and make a couple of videos well
I am I am excited excited I have a big
console excited in a long time oh you
already do that like I've been so down
on Xbox for so long man
just knowing that anything is we don't
know anything really we just we just
know of a box that looks like it can it
can be something that we want it to be
but there's only one review on my
channel and it's a second of myth of
hell bleh I
that review when it came to xbox I love
that game and when I saw that game and I
saw it rendered in 4k an engine mmm
I don't care what anybody says cuz I
felt like if you didn't play you
frightened if you didn't play hell-blade
[ __ ] I got why I got one for you I
think you fraud and if you didn't play
with headphones look I played that D
with headphones in like bro
that game was so transformative to me in
the way that I played I don't bear it's
single handedly broke like the way you
use sound in a game yes I ever seen a
game sound mind you how many people made
that game yeah 20 people 20 people 20
people so that was my elbows to probably
the biggest standout for me and then
honestly the rest of the show is much
like I don't want to say it was a blur
because that's a bad way to say it right
but the rest of the show went it flows
so well that I have to literally look at
this again to say yes yeah man yes I
missed because we because part of the
stuff they announced it was like we we
were so excited but we sure did we were
so recover our minds are still blown
from the the Xbox announcement damn it's
like the next year I would just Rahman
was somewhere I was just like yo I can't
believe that just happened
you know I'm gonna say something here
and this is this isn't this is not
console war BS because everyone knows I
own all the consoles everyone knows how
I feel about Sony's first party I'm day
one and all of them I beat them all or
played them all but I have to say Xbox
within the first 10 minutes of the show
basically walked up what Phil dominus
did today was walk up it dropped the mic
and was out and as great as the show was
I mean like I said grateful day one by
four I mean God God fooled a 1x4 me
ghostess machine with day one by for me
but dropping a new cup not just dropping
the name but showing the console showing
up
troller and then following it by saying
oh I'm gonna show you something that's a
bet that's a little ways Alex what I
thought people need to see this and wow
wow and I gotta jump it because that was
the significance you nailed a boom again
if they would have done any one of those
by themselves individually it wouldn't
have had the impact right because Harold
late we didn't okay that's cool was
coming is it on what what is it on then
we got the name right we got the name
dang you like okay not only you getting
a name you're getting the physical look
all he rocks right yeah garlic if you
look like refrigerator or whatever
that's it'll be on the point looks like
a rig you could make fun of it all you
want but that's what a rig looks like
the Xbox X could make horizontal I'm
fine does that know what it all vertical
all day you know I'm saying and then you
show in supposedly this is what they
said when he said it it's in game and
this is in game engine running on the on
the sex box that's crazy
that's crazy and this is for the Xbox
faithful this is what they've been
clamoring from those oh how did they
keep this secret I don't think they had
to really keep a lot secret because it
was already out that it was what the
system was it was just a bunch of people
going around wondering what this if
these specs are right if this specs is
right the thing that they kept on the
wrap was just the fact that they already
had a render of what the system actually
looked like and the name of it didn't
leak so and I think Microsoft the I
think they're smart because if they
probably just came up with probably over
the next over the last couple of weeks
and it was like we got the game Awards
coming up we're not gonna be able to
hold this as a secret until February or
March of next year let's put this out
now get our base happy which is
something that we've all been hoping
they it ever says last year don't it's
not the time to tease anymore
it's the time of action and I think that
was the one thing that I liked the most
and when I saw the system I see the
possibilities of everything that they've
been saying about being the most
powerful system today I think I mean at
last point I just get right back to you
more I think also again is that let's be
real the game Awards this is the Oscars
of gaming yes yes well you have the most
I so as much as if I gotta give them
credit big time on this because at the
end of the day we always complain like
yo they don't know how to get to take
advantage of the moment to galvanize the
base and even though if they would've
did their own reveal on their own show
that would have been fine but you do
this to the world
everyone's watching that's setting the
tone that's stealing the done it that's
how you do a reveal and that's why I
probably is he broke protocol and now
let he do that
he showed something early you know said
he showed something that was triple-a
that wasn't kiddie that everybody wants
let's be real no disrespect to a
bleeding edge but he'll blade is the
game from it yeah not in the game you
want that's the one that people have had
their eyes on like this little indie
studio now with this financial backing
to man that's how you do it my game a
little bit but but it's not just that
it's the advertisement of the Box I'm
looking at it right now it says the new
Xbox Series X and this is how it's
written and fastest period most powerful
period listen they have to know
something that we don't know about the
next generation consoles and that
includes Sony for them to put this on
the packaging this is you understand
that this is the Xbox one X all over
again because when they put that out
they knew they had the most powerful box
they have just said that again the
fastest and most powerful you don't put
that out there 11 months before launch
unless you are goddamn sure yeah you
don't say who are the fastest and most
powerful
we have heard rumors PS by the way that
Sony has already started talking about
the the PS 5 Pro well yeah they want to
continue with a mid generation wait why
would they talk about that so far in
soso come on man it's 11 months before
the PS 5 comes out I mean I don't go too
crazy with that cuz I'm you know
obviously I think it's something when
they spoke today shout the mods he broke
the story once again I think it's one of
those things that they they're gonna
mimic the next generation it's
interesting to see if it's a reactionary
thing I don't know hold on Victor Alex
Tina - awesome chat now you can fake
having a PC with the series but Gabe
booba Gator for day no listen this this
this was let me tell you something
think about how ballsy this having this
not even at your own show where you can
control it yeah where you can control it
this is someone else's show and this
opened the Game Awards because by all
rights this is something where you you
shut down the show with but they started
to show with this I just liked it there
I like you could definitely tell that
they're going after a different market
with systems like this because of the
naming conventions of it like we're
always wondering what the next version
could be named Xbox serious X I just see
I just see it be an SX like like how
iPhone does it and how an Andrea like
their galaxy phones it's like this is
the SS version of the system uh me
personally man this this changes
everything for a lot of people you know
especially like I said it comes down to
that price point but that's the price
the price point is gonna matter but I
look me being this kind of puts more in
line when it comes to them actually
making two systems depending on what the
system you know what the price is going
to be you know Phil Spencer came out and
did say that they're gonna keep it price
great price comparative to the PS 5
he personally I feel like if you're
gonna come out with a la carte that's
gonna beat me at a lower price this
system needs to be everything right and
I feel like this system is this would be
the system that's gonna bridge that gap
between gamers that want to play on
console like PC experience if you can
give me a PC experience with this what
are all the extra crap that I got to
deal with on a PC I do oh I'll play
exclusively on this system yeah I mean I
stink shot that pixel pitch et Ossa but
yet they leaked it to Jeff so he doesn't
leak it like no indication know what the
Lockhart will be available at launch
that's a good question that's a good
question yeah I mean it seems like the
marketing would you guys agree that they
vote deep even though we know the
Lockhart exists the marketing seem to be
only pushing the bigger system right the
key is gonna be how they implement it
how they market both if Lockhart is
gonna be available at launch and then
obviously I think that they listen
here's the thing okay we talked about
this today on the Xbox Factor podcast a
shame shame shame was plug um no doubt
you have to understand what we saw the
swagger yeah I'm gonna watch this again
but look at Phil Spencer this was a
different Phil on that stage okay he
walked out there and if he you know I'm
saying he walked out there with a
different type of swagger because he
knew what they have and I am telling you
this right now the the the nice guy Phil
the gentleman Phil was gonna it is gonna
be put to the side come next generation
and they're going for the jugular and I
think I think that if they want to get a
stranglehold early on the because
remember Sony won the generation from
the video this is how you share games
right the generation was done right from
there was done even when they were had
they didn't didn't have
good first party games their fanbase
waited all those years for 2018 and and
you know what I'm saying and and that's
why they have been so popular but they
if they come out next year and this box
is $500 for $99.99 and the Lockhart is
two hundred and ninety nine thousand
ninety nine cents and it's more powerful
than the X but obviously less powerful
than the PS five and and the sex box
they're gonna Bev in a back Sony into a
corner because Sony is not coming out
for anything less than five hundred
they're gonna match them in price Sony
cannot take a loss solving their fill of
continuing the mantra of no power
greater than X series X makes perfect
sense when you think about it yeah the
interesting vidcon says Microsoft game
plan has always been to bring PC power
to console sensibilities they're finally
giving it with the XS X
letlet ban sex box out here is literally
sex is looking strong you know we got
again the price for he's gonna be key
but again kudos to the team because
again one of my biggest complaints has
been marketing and knowing the moment
and this is how you do it you continue
to do this now like I said four things
from your point on the bar is said the
coins you want to do for your big if you
do this these type of things for your
base at these type of announcement those
one moment things telling you your fans
are gonna ride out that that's area and
then show the games show them mature
titles you have no problem but I got to
get him credit for sitting on that cuz
after XO nineteen member was a little
spooky for some some people this is what
they showcasing and he's sad on this and
he ate that so I you know kudos to film
the fact that they showed the system and
then they show a they show we all kept
talking about it it's like no kiddie
games here no low graphic development
here they put that game out and they
swung with something with everybody
wanted to see which one in just theories
game everyone is
as everybody probably wanted to see a
newer game I'll tell you he'll bleed you
know I sequel I will hit you
Randall it is the magic question go you
know that's not you know you know that's
that's exclusive to I love I live the
life that mooch lives if he if anything
that he when he says the whole bring it
to your base first it didn't release it
everywhere second I'm a hunter sit in
for that I can still see it's gonna
probably be on game that it's gonna be
in game pad so it's gonna probably be on
PC and Xbox because Xbox wants to build
that ecosystem that our SSX is a PC
right you could play it you just play it
like a console but I wouldn't be
surprised because he'll plate is on it's
on ps4 was on ps4 first and it's all
switch I would be surprised six months
to a year later it makes that release or
no systems but at that point much Sony's
Microsoft's already made his money off
of Wow xxx box day one it'll be
interesting to see the narrative I mean
I can see a situation possibly but then
they they've said conflicting messages
well known on the air but you know you
got to remember he booty came out and
said when people started talking about
the old games gonna be on other people
he said no no our first party games is
staying on on the console until I see it
I gotta see the only thing I'm concerned
about boomers I remember a statement
that when they said they acquire certain
games and certain games had
relationships or deals
yeah but the Ninja Theory wasn't one of
them okay the ninja said that if
anything it would have been the smaller
game made by 15 people that that that's
like power stone that would have been a
game that would have been in that
contract the hell blade to is completely
a Microsoft IP and I am i I don't I
don't think that they released that
yeah well then but but you see that but
this is dude this is marketing master
master craft because what happens is if
you were hell blade fan on the
PlayStation you now have to go buy an
Xbox
now to that to that that point where the
price not the price of entry but just to
people that are in the ecosystem when it
releases you know a lot of like a lot of
this stuff happened for Microsoft just
because it was weaker sales on their
console that's how game passes
everything was created that's how play
anywhere and was created as stuffing so
I really just comes down to that but the
one thing I do want to do as it's being
balanced in this whole situation is this
is a great day for Xbox fans forget just
in gamers in general just just being
able to see something and actually get
excited because we always talk we
haven't had that moment as an Xbox fan
what what was our shiny like oh my god
moment
this was our oh my god mode we can
actually say we finally got one but
guess what this is only the beginning
Maira still has a long way to go right
we celebrate this and be happy for the
direction that they're going in and we
and we basically celebrate it but we
don't need to think that this is this is
a de norm until we start be the norm all
I'm willing to say that field ominous
spencer as of right now has won the day
yes it's just one part of the battle the
war hasn't even started yet then we
gotta remove myself as final super chat
think you've seen the clip again with
Phil if you see the caprica he said he
states 15 studios creating exclusively
so I think he'll blade is exclusive
interests yeah I think we were so we
were so awestruck all of us nobody was
in attention to anything other than the
Raider you have done you know yeah
there's something that no one has
mentioned I'm gonna say it again
tomorrow on percocet boom this is the
first game rewards that unveiled a new
console yeah
okay in the history of the show this has
never happened before and it opened the
show yes with this and let's be real I
gotta give them credit again if you
followed normal protocol normal protocol
is technically not to show your system
here normal protocol would be old-school
way of thinking you have a Microsoft
only press event right will you show the
system maybe like February March of 2020
or something like that right with like
you just talked about the hardware and
that was it and then they'll say come
back
III and we'll show you the games and
that that's generally the flow of things
so this signifies the importance of him
breaking protocol right there's
something we always complain about like
they don't they not being transparent
they not giving us a peek it is right
just a peek and not only did you show a
peek
yo your girl was looking phenomenal in
that yeah like I Got News for you the
the event in early spring that or you
know February March that were that
they're talking about doing for the for
the Xbox is going to be Lockhart and
they're gonna show games because they
got the big daddy already outs no can
you go be the best judo boom you can't
confuse people listen I Got News for you
this is a good start man this is this is
this is laying the groundwork and
honestly I don't think they take back
steps from here I think that they
understand that they've made these
massive mistakes and they just need Phil
to get out there and talk don't let
anyone else talk let Phil go out there
and do his thing
and you don't have a problem with the
messaging shout out the slow-mo
foretaste of Hell blade to look so good
he may actually play a game for that but
real quick before we get out I just
wanted to recap as far as the awards
itself everything else for me personally
the show I thought it was arguably the
best Game Awards ever know they set the
tone
we had a console reveal we had from
in this room we got a ps5 that goes
agreed for God fool God won't look crazy
you know they said to turn with that
that was fantastic you know and let's be
real that's let's call it how it is we
gotta call it fair at the end of the day
shout the victory let's see I was on
Amazon stating standing Stadium on X 2
and Xbox to Xbox salute I think we gotta
call it fair a lot of us thought this
was gonna be the Jeff standing situation
I mean Jenna did win I kind of wonder
like listen listen my show was [ __ ] ok
I'm small I don't even got three
thousand subs but but he did respond to
me personally and I know that rich
review tech did a big video to hit like
a hundred thousand views and
upper-echelon game did a whole back
story on the history of kojima i think i
could be wrong and i'm not gonna talk
about this on my show cuz i've talked
about the death and quite frankly I'm
sick of it yeah but I think that the
public pressure has has has made an
impact I think the voices of the people
were hurt because this had nine
nominations and it won three okay and it
did not win game of the year keeping the
streak of the Louis meta being 85 for
for a game to win dude I mean listen
there's been a lot of scandal and and I
really I don't
again I this is complete speculation but
it is it seems as if the public pressure
might have played of serious role
interesting look man at the end of the
day all our gonna say what that is on
you know definitely surprised because I
you know I thought it might be a Royal
Flush situation you know hold six listen
I'm gonna tell you the game let me tell
you what a game what started off right
for me for it a with destiny won an
award I was like oh my love it's about
trying to get something whether you hate
it
whatever you feel about it it is one of
the best communities and you see them at
least win
even though there was crickets in the
crowd and they did it before the show
but are you gonna let that slide we won
it's still won an award now say we got
some tremendous reveals so you thought
I'm saying just hey you know what I
liked it they did boom and all endeavor
they kind of skim through the esport
stuff and no disrespect guys but now you
know that's the stuff that I want off
screen sometimes and sometimes you do
want those awards you know other Wars
kind of presented so that was really
cool death you still with us I want to
get your highlights before we roll out
to it now and forth I am here yeah I
mean I'm glad people who deserve the
award actually won the award in my
opinion like Best narrative I can
understand people jumping on different
bandwagon out the disco disco museum is
an old-school RPG and one thing those
are known for is amazing stories okay
they may not look the part but this
story's always top-notch some of you
it's understandable now game of the year
sukira well desert no one can hate on
that I mean overall it's just quick show
the awards went to cool the reward [ __ ]
then there's plenty for everyone it
doesn't matter which platform you
support everyone got something everybody
got to shine off on all he goes gamed I
was her little goose goose a Wyndham but
other than that Nintendo came through
smash came through a lot of stuff oh
shout the Fire Emblem remember people
were worried what about the awards for
you for it say like where's yet with the
awards themselves okay I have to make
the I have to agree I I think that when
you look at the awards the death
stranding that um like the the the you
know the voice the voice could have it
could have went either way it could have
went to Norman Reedus it could have went
to May I think it's Mads Mikkelsen right
what you call a form yes yes so I mean
they want for that what would work with
the other to the death trending one and
and you know what honestly you can't
argue that because like I said even
though the game seems like it's not for
me because and like I said I'm a play
because my brother do you know that neo
Mentos my brother has a hundred and
twenty hours in that game dizzy said it
once soundtrack yeah leave a window
sound award to okay so when the
soundtrack okay so I mean I mean that
could have went to anyone but I mean
again a lot of people you know listen it
the one thing about kojima games they do
have good sound i will give him that
credit but i again I have to say I agree
with the statement I think that the
people that won the awards actually
deserve the awards that they walked away
with like I didn't see anything even
like wait a second that seems a little
off yes it seemed as if every one that
walked away with one and they were
allows I mean there were a lot of
surprises yeah I mean listen you know I
you know what listen it's my personal
game of the year resin able to remake
has now moved to number one and moved
and resonable to 98 has moved to number
two of my all-time forty plus two your
gaming career that's one and two that's
for me I don't know if it would I mean I
think that everything about the game is
amazing but a lot of people like we're
but it's a remake you know what I'm
saying
Oh we'll see what will I mean listen
again it's I'm happy you know I'm really
happy for secure oh yeah oh I'm happy
because there are so many people that
just I mean I played it I bought the
collector's edition I did an unboxing
I'm terrible at it I'll admit it I
that's fine I just don't have the
patience like that but there are so many
people that loved that game and I and I
think that at the end of the day it's it
it was well deserving up absolutely just
the streams alone the engagement people
doing you know trying to beat the bosses
I mean
it became you know that the new version
of Dark Souls for this year and I just I
thought it was tremendous put up no it's
late it's about midnight y'all I'm still
we still on the high that's how excited
we are that's how crazy to show the
testament to the show but I'll let
everybody rap out boom wicked if I'm
people find you man what you got going
on tomorrow what's going on man well in
um let's see ten hours which I'm going
to try and see for know what I don't
know I may have I may have to decompress
and and watch the Phil Spencer Dominus
come out again and because this was this
is like this was like the old w's WCW
days when actually feel come walking out
I think of Hollywood Hogan coming out
that's what I'm thinking I know yeah if
you want to follow me I mean like I said
that everything everybody in the
community knows who I am but if you're
new I say welcome you can follow me on
twitter at mr. boomstick XL I do three
live shows per week I do lots of lots of
coverage lots of live coverage six plus
hours a week of content that you can
just you can just suck up whenever you
want a lot up a new production values to
the show show notes
you know the commercials are now spread
out so there's no no bunching I'm
learning I'm learning the tricks of the
trade so if you're interested head over
to double-barrel gaming and I think you
will find something that you like and
more importantly tomorrow morning at
10:00 a.m. breakfast with boom I have a
ridiculous cast and it's gonna it's
gonna be who who's on tomorrow we got we
got so shady we got big cloud gaming we
got dread pool
we have zemi games and we have crispy
bomb and it's gonna it's a it's gonna be
a show that's probably gonna be
dominated by the game Awards and I had
written five topics I don't think I'm
actually gonna get to because I think
that they can seriously like I just
think that they're they're just too big
the game Awards is just it could
logistically take up a two hour show
just like it did this evening
we may read the Reg and have builded
always shall salute the read your salute
to you guys man for correctly predicting
yeah we're hike bro we've been talking
about it for so long I'll give ran a
real copper recap because that's royalty
that's a good friend to the realm
yeah we just said ran like you know the
consensus here is this is how you do it
and this is what the Xbox fans the base
it's how you galvanize the basis
something that PlayStation has done so
well that switch has done so well and
see Phil come out on that stage not only
we get the name not only we get to look
then we get he'll play too in engine
looking phenomenal the game that we walk
from Ninja Theory no disrespect to play
- but this is the game that we've been
waiting and it just was phenomenal man
it was tremendous thing that the pacing
was good at the show I mean I think from
that point we all agree the ball was set
so high that you wish we were still
decompressing we're still trying to
figure out like wow did we just see what
we just saw you know I'm saying they
broke protocol that's how you do it
and now what I'm gonna say ran the bar
is set man like that this is how Xbox
fans wanna feel during these shows you
gotta say like this is what we would but
ya did salute to Phil you just you
cannot spend a filter see he was filled
ominous today he earns a king will be
praising him or today but oh yeah
shouting gears tactics that was for me I
love XCOM I love to see I don't like
that it looked like it's only PC but
that's another story put on yeah that
was tremendous ghost Ashima looked
amazing I felt like you said boom the
games that deserve to win kind of one I
really didn't have any time but I was
like ah this is BS and Brad destiny won
an award so I don't wanna hear your
mouth to watch it was a really great
show and you can find me on Twitter same
name I'm guessing I and yeah there's it
was that was the best show Jeff and he
does a round of applause because
it was a tad little too long you know
what they showed it was substance real
substance getting everyone what didn't I
watch on hearing no - out - slow-mo he
said it's coming to Xbox Kia's tax they
showed it for Xbox game passed it in
hope so man cuz I definitely love that
hopefully they can get those type of
games
oh do they they're gonna get the
controls figured out I mean if they
could do it for Halo or Wars - they can
easily do forgive tactics phenomenal but
we are gonna get out it's midnight week
we all hate y'all we all - you going he
still making videos right now you good
everybody you already know the laws on
Sunday y'all know what it is thanks for
rocking out everybody enjoy yet night
I'm gonna rewatch that trailer Woodfill
dobby's yeah I'm watching and watch the
now before sleep I'm gonna be honest
with you everybody
[Music]